do you think one day will be possible to
simulate the full history
that took our solar system to what it is
today
yes and it will be useless okay so you
don't think
your story many of the ideas that you
have about jupiter clear in the space
like retelling that story in high
resolution is not that important
i actually think it's important but at
every stage
you have to you have to simul you have
to
design your experiments your your
numerical computer experiments so that
they test some specific aspect of that
evolution
got it um i am not a proponent
of doing huge simulations because
um even if we forget the
information theory aspect of not being
able
to simulate in full detail the universe
because if you do then you
you have made an actual universe it's
not the simulation
right by simulation is in some sense a
compression
of information so therefore you must
lose detail
but that point aside if we are able to
simulate the entire history of the solar
system in excruciating detail
i mean it'll be cool but it's not going
to be
any different from observing it
right because theoretical understanding
which is what
ultimately i'm interested in
comes from taking complex things and
reducing them down to something
that you know some mechanism that you
can actually quantify
um that's the that's the fun part of
astrophysics
just kind of simulating things in
extreme detail
is we'll cool we'll make cool
visualizations but that doesn't get to
doesn't doesn't get you to any better
understanding than you had before
you did the simulation if you ask very
specific questions then you'll be able
to
uh create like very highly compressed
nice beautiful theories about how things
evolved and then you can use those to
then generalize to other solar systems
to other stars and other galaxies and
say something generalizable about the
entire universe
how difficult would it be to simulate
our solar system such that we would not
know the difference
meaning if we are living in a simulation
is there a nice think of it as a video
game sure is there a nice compressible
way of doing that
or just kind of like you intuited with a
three-body
situation is just a giant mess that you
cannot create a video game
that uh will seem realistic without
actually building universities so i'm
you know i'm speculating but one of the
yeah i know i know like you have a deep
understanding of this
but like for me i'm just gonna like
speculate that
for um at least
in the types of simulations that we can
do today
inevitably you run into the problem of
resolution
right you're doesn't matter what you're
doing it is discrete
now um the way you would go about asking
you know if what we're observing is that
a simulation
or uh or is that you know some real
continuous
thing uh is you you zoom in right you
zoom in and try and find
the you know the grid scale if you will
um yeah i mean
it's a it's a really interesting it's a
really interesting question
and because the
solar system itself and really you know
the double pendulum is chaotic
right pendulum sitting on another
pendulum
it moves unpredictably once you let them
go
um you really don't need to like inject
any randomness into a simulation for it
to
to give you stochastic and unpredictable
answers
weather is a great example of this
weather has a lap enough time
of you know typical weather systems have
a happen of time of a few days
and there's a fundamental reason why the
force
forecast always sucks you know two weeks
in advance
it's not that we don't know the
equations that
govern the atmosphere we know them well
their solutions are meaningless though
after a few days
the zooming in thing is very interesting
you